joining us here on the Rich Eisen show
as Brad Faxon how are you Brad great
rich how are you it's been it's been a
while since I was hanging out with you
and an Android at your awesome annual
events and what you know I still
received the mailings and what you guys
do for kids is amazing Brad really is we
had a pretty good run there with some of
the greatest celebrities as athletes and
just we were lucky to have everybody
like you come to Rhode Island to help us
raise money for kids just amazing and
we'll get more on on how folks can get
involved later on in our chat but I do
want to get first and foremost to the
topic du jour and that is you know what
Mickelson did over the weekend and we
will talk about ketki because obviously
he deserves to have the dimension but
your what what do you think of Mickelson
and how he handled the weekend's events
Brad well you know it's interesting rich
that you'd start off with Mickelson at
the top because I've been asked by I've
done a couple media shows this morning
and and say Wingo and garlic asked me
who's gonna remember what's going to be
remembered the most will be kept cos
repeat victory the the USGA and kind of
their gas again or or still Nicholson
and I think Nicholson is winning this by
a landslide yeah I know we that's I
guess great radio shows if you will
think alike I mean you want to update
the as the poll question of Brad Faxon
yeah Brad we're kind of asking the same
thing what are you gonna remember most
the course conditions Phil's controversy
or kepco going back to back no it's
unfortunately it's going to be still by
a landslide in the statement that he
made and you know I said on the air on
our opening yesterday that I don't know
that this was totally premeditated but I
think though it was calculated and what
I mean by that was he was trying to make
a statement to the USGA that they've
gone overboard recently they made some
mistakes not only in 2004 Shinnecock
number 7 poll but also with their course
setup and maybe the choices in the golf
courses like Aaron Hill
last year or chambers Bay two years
three years ago and you know Mickelson's
been the bridesmaid six times Neelix
opens four times in the state of New
York but I don't know that he's getting
over this part of a thirteen cold for
bogey thinking I'm gonna hit this by
intentionally so that I can run after it
one time it back up and get out here
yeah I think it was you know he reached
the boiling point he had a few things
happen in the round it wasn't playing
particularly well and he knew that ball
is gonna roll off the Gant green and
then kind of figured out where it was
gonna end up was not in a good spot so
instead of stopping it he hit it while I
was in motion and what's up unbelievable
is you know there is a penalty for
hitting a ball in motion and it can
happen in a lot of different situations
but I think when you stop the ball
intentionally that would be
disqualification he might have known
that but if you watched his actions
afterwards with beef Johnson as you know
its partner and how they laughed about
it and then kinda how is he stumbled a
couple different interviews I don't
think he really realized at the time
what he was doing other than who
couldn't make a fool myself this ball
goes down there cuz he simply could have
just taken an unplayable lying read the
pot he could have been then there's tip
for him to say that he knew the rule at
the time which is something that beef
did not back up it's it's just terribly
unfortunate Brad and you know and then
oh folks like yourself as well as the
USGA now have to stand in the firing
line saying do you think he was telling
the truth or not and and whether that
that matters what do you think he but
then let me put it this way do you think
he should have withdrawn Brad well it's
so similar to me to the drop Tiger Woods
took mistakenly took back in the Masters
you know I believe that was 2013 we at
the flagstick on 50th olds third shot
ball goes caroming off the pin back into
the water and then went back to replay
the shot didn't do it from the exact
position later admitted in the press
room and assigned the scorecard and the
Masters organization you know everybody
wants to put it on an organization
is not someone that gets plain
singularly said no we're going to come
up with this obscure rule and let him
play obviously knowing the ladings and
tigers appeal sex appeal out there is so
important and then you know the same
john bodenheimer and david sorry Michael
Davis from the USGS said they have their
committee and the you know the rulings I
can't remember the numbers and the
rulings but they said no there's a
little-used rule and that's what they
used to allow him to play now I think if
if Phil withdrew I think he would have
been admitting that he broke a rule and
I don't think he thinks he broke a rule
in you know so my reaction to the whole
thing like everybody else was shocked
and surprised there was you've never
seen that before and you know you might
see many Christians wearing a bracelet
that says what would Jesus do WWJD I
always try to think well it all what
would I do you know if he was you know
our ring bearer
he Arnold would have never done that
Jack would have never done that you know
Ben Hogan would have never done that so
I to me this was similar to to Phil's
statement at the Ryder Cup in 2014 at
Gleneagles when the Americans kind of
got destroyed and Phil was protesting
the captaincy of Tom Watson and in the
press conference kind of went out and
spoke out against him in front of
everyone in front of the world really so
in a way I think this is his way of
getting back at the USGA Brad Faxon here
on the Rich Eisen show and I think part
and parcel is why this is still being
talked about instead of Brooks koepka is
because it is just part of a larger
picture as to what the USGA wants the US
Open to be do what do they want it to be
Brad what what does the US do they want
it to be the toughest tournament on
planet earth do they want it to be a
situation where the the best players in
the world are brought to their knees and
that it's the course that
means I'm wondering what what is the
answer to that question well they have a
new word instead of tough it's ultimate
they want it to be the ultimate test and
for years it has been whatever you want
to use is a description as an adjective
to to it and the golf courses have
traditionally been narrow fairways
extremely thick rough a foot off the
fairway treeline golf courses that are
traditional and parkland style golf
courses if you think of Fox got this
contract with the USC now this is our
fourth open since chambers Bay in 2015 I
don't think there's combined in those
four golf courses twenty trees on the
full courses chambers Bay had one
Oakmont had thousands thousands removed
Aaron Hill had virtually none and then
what happened at Shinnecock was there
were 500 or so removed and that looks
more like a link style plays more like a
link style course so I think what
happens is the architecture ideal of
mike davis the executive committee there
is to try and go back to what the
original intent was which wasn't what
the player saw on Oh 4 or 95 so it was
very different than what players
expected a lot of these closely bone
areas around the greens were balls with
carom off greens and you could pop them
off a green like you saw in 13 and 15 or
there's a very difficult 10th 10th green
with balls with ricochet 50 yards behind
the green and and I think that's what is
come up now is what are you guys how are
you gonna identify yourself Tom layman
called me two nights ago in an uproar
about you know what do they do it you
know this has been the most respected
tournament for years and now it's kind
of gone haywire and admittedly they made
a mistake on camera with us on Saturday
evening
so yeah I think they need to somehow
find a way to right this ship and I
guess my suggestion immunity to hire a
very good PR firm
would be step one that would be step one
all right so let's get to Brooks koepka
Brad how good is he and what what did
this weekend tell you about him well
he's amazing and in a lot of reasons why
I couldn't believe that this guy who's
been out for a couple of years with a
wrist injury I mean I saw a couple
months with a wrist injury earlier this
year could come back and and dominate
the way he did and he does it with a few
different ways you've seen these biceps
because he could be a minute middle line
back on almost any NBA team it looks
like I'm sorry NFL team he looks so big
and fit that it would be awkward or hard
for him to swing and he and his buddy
Dustin Johnson was the second or last
pairing they worked out for an hour and
a half both Saturday and Sunday mornings
with her trainer Jonas Alvey they lift
heavy weights they smash it and go at
each other in so many different ways and
it's incredible to how well he putted
this we can eat why the reason why he
wanted a single reason why
Tiger Woods dominated his error and why
Dustin Johnson won at Oakmont we opened
two years ago and that was by the
proximity to the pin from what we call
approach shots from a hundred and fifty
to two hundred and twenty-five yards he
just kept lacing iron shots close he was
second in the for the week and the
putting stats folks gained he didn't
really hit a lot of fairways you know
anybody could muscle it out I don't know
if you saw some of the shots from some
of this rough that's just so good but it
was it was impressive wasn't it it
really was Brad it really was and you
know we had we had fun runs second era
with Joe nailing the name of of Brooks
is significant other this time around
yeah yeah you bet the way he just just
laid into it he got this one rod that's
I love Joe Joe it's just that's Bucky
and that's as good that's Joe at his
finest as you guys all work to I really
enjoyed the coverage before I let you go
folks can go to the website and read
facts in charities org
and donate correct that's right yes so
Billy and I started that back in 1992 we
were lucky enough to get a bunch of the
Boston celebrities there like Bobby Orr
we had Sandy Koufax Julius Erving
Charles Barkley Danny Sullivan I mean
those names go back Glenn Frey Joe Pesci
Bill Murray I mean we were impressed
Rich Eisen Sean McDonough Mike Tirico
come on I said Bill Raftery we had fun
there you have to admit and yeah to
raised over eight million dollars for
children's charities and state it was
fun and don't forget the family brothers
Brad they put you an ad right in the in
the beginning of kingpin come on now the
Abhiyan Peter no they were great they
would auction off parts of their movies
hi I'm doing just service because I know
I'm gonna leave big no-no what dokey
yeah but Andre tip that remembers a
great middle linebacker for the Patriots
come on we had everybody Steve Grogan
play it was a blast what was it what was
it like shooting that scene in kingpin
were you dressed in disco 70 gear and
there's Woody Harrelson and the rest of
[Laughter]
its burg outside an old ice-cream parlor
and what the best part was Bill Murray
came up he wasn't in the scene we were
doing the scene with Woody Harrelson
Billy and I and we decided to have a
contest while they were changing the
scene set throwing rocks at a telephone
pole from like 20 feet away and the
Farrelly Brothers they liked to have fun
so that we're out there pitching rocks
from like 20 30 yards away and Murray
comes and he kind of grabs this kind of
big almost like a boulder and he goes
running up to this telephone pole to
throw the boulder and 20 misses and it
gets going on his down slope on this
road it was kind of like a little office
down the bottom of this hill like 20 30
yards down the hill and the rock
starting to pick up speed ins going
right at this car as the woman who holds
the car comes out of the the door to the
office and she's watching this rock
she's looking at us screaming and
yelling and then looking at her car is
about to get assaulted by this Boulder
and somehow it's about to smash into the
driver side door it gets
I'm telling you this is a big big rock
right before it gets the car it like
hits this bump or speed bump and kicks
over at the top of the car and never
touches it and it was the grandest thing
everything don't worry starts high so I
eat you up there puts the brakes on
comes on she I can't believe you do my
god it helps be Bill Murray helps me
Bill Murray and I was about to say I'm
glad there was that bump because Phil
wasn't around to stop the boulder and
deflected right that's called both
circle Brad's called full circle thanks
for joining
chatting good luck you got it Santa
Billy for me that's Brad Faxon the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience